cierran las urnas en francia los
franceses votaron en la primera ronda de
las elecciones legislativas
primordiales para determinar si el
gobierno de manuel macro conserva la
mayoría en el parlamento frente a la
coalición opositora de izquierda y otras
fuerzas el alto abstencionismo fue
protagonista tenemos reportes desde
parís
rusia dijo que destruyó un gran depósito
de armas estadounidenses y europeas en
la región de ternopil en el oeste de
ucrania en el este siguen los combates
en cervera 110 donde se reporta la
destrucción por parte de los rusos de un
puente que conecta con la vecina
lysychansk que dificulta la evacuación
de civiles
este domingo se conmemora el día
internacional contra el trabajo infantil
según naciones unidas 1 de cada 10 niños
y niñas trabaja en el mundo lo que eleva
la cifra unos 160 millones un equipo de
france 24 fue a esta costa de márfil en
donde se estima que cientos de miles de
niños trabajan en plantaciones de qatar
bienvenidos a este resumen de
informativo en francés 24 los acompaña
daniel hablando comenzamos en francia en
donde ya cerraron las urnas en la
primera de dos rondas legislativas en
menos de dos meses después de la
reelección de manuel macrón éste
enfrenta un fuerte desafío de un bloque
unido de izquierda que podría frenar su
agenda de programas sociales y
económicos
las primeras proyecciones de ipsos son
sobras seria para france24 dicen que no
en nueva unión popular económica y
social que es la coalición encabezada
por el partido francia insumisa de
jean-luc mélenchon los verdes y los
socialistas tendría entre 150 y 190
asientos en el parlamento que está
conformado por 577 curules y en el que
se necesitan 200 89 escaños para tener
mayoría absoluta por su parte la
coalición juntos de manuel macro ni sus
aliados tendría entre 255 y 295 sillas
los partidos de centroderecha
encabezados por él adicional los
republicanos obtendrían entre 50 y 80
escaños la agrupación nacional de marine
lepén de extrema derecha tendría entre
20 y 45
y ya tenemos las primeras reacciones a
estas estimaciones marie le pen del
partido de extrema derecha
agrupación nacional y quien se me dio en
la segunda vuelta presidencial contra el
reelecto mandatario emanuel macrón
invitó a derrotar al oficialismo en la
segunda vuelta dimos curso el próximo
domingo es importante no dejar que
manuel macrón tenga una mayoría de la
que abusara para impulsar su agenda auto
céntrica y nos imponga su proyecto
antisocial para hacer lo que quiera
cuando quiera pero sin ti y contra ti a
otro plan mesón es su vocación y en el
mismo sentido se pronunció jean luc
mélenchon el líder de francia insumisa
que pertenece a la coalición de
izquierda nueva unión popular económica
y social el núcleo
por antonio por primera vez en la quinta
república un presidente recién elegido
no ha logrado establecer una mayoría en
las elecciones legislativas en curso 'la
elección registra chiquis hago un
llamado a nuestro pueblo para que
aproveche esta extraordinaria
oportunidad de votar en masa el próximo
domingo sap en otro pueblo
a desearlo por excursión para abordar
estas elecciones conectamos con natalia
ruiz nuestra corresponsal en parís
natalia a cuáles han sido las primeras
reacciones tras conocerse estas
estimaciones iniciales y en qué posición
quedan en manuel macro ni sus aliados
frente a la posibilidad o no de
conservar una mayoría parlamentaria
muy buenas tardes pues ahorita
justamente ustedes escuchaban arroyo que
melón son a quien escuchamos aquí en la
sede de las nubes hace unos minutos el
muy emocionado y más allá de todo pues
se dijo sobre todo que el partido oeste
a mayoría presidencial era un partido
que estaba acabado una mayoría
presidencial que había sido vencida y
por eso pues pedía finalmente que se
confirmara esto la próxima semana por su
parte manuel amat con quien uno no ha
hecho declaraciones a la prensa pero si
ya sabemos por parte del elíseo qué es
lo que pidió a toda su bancada pues es
recibir estos resultados con bastante
humildad y bueno enfrentar lo que viene
a lo largo de esta semana de hecho
elisabeth bone la primera ministra ella
sí se dirigió a la prensa ella clasificó
a la siguiente vuelta en algo de
calvados en estas elecciones
legislativas y dijo que finalmente pues
está su fuerza política o la fuerza
política a la que pertenece es la única
capaz de lograr a tener esa mayoría en
la asamblea nacional y también dijo pues
que finalmente francia se podría estar
hasta está ante la amenaza de una e
inestabilidad política en caso de que la
izquierda logre esa mayoría en la
asamblea nacional así que así como verán
pues esto es el enfrentamiento que se
está dando finalmente entre manuela
damasco y el son luís - o a lo largo de
toda esta jornada y de todo lo que debe
suceder o va a suceder a lo largo de
toda esta última semana de campaña antes
del próximo domingo y para hacer ese
análisis también nos acompaña desde
parís de pascal de lujo analista
político y especialista en relaciones
internacionales señor pascal buenas
noches para usted gracias por
acompañarnos en france 24 y comencemos
comentando estos primeros estimaciones
de resultados de la primera vuelta
electoral que resaltaría usted de esta
votación
pues daniela me parece que
hoy en día vamos con una nueva asamblea
tres polos
juntos la plataforma la cronista
la nube es esa unión plataforma de
izquierda
y luego mucho más lejos
las derechas
a esa confrontación como bien se llegó
es inédita porque el bloque de izquierda
está liderado por la extrema izquierda
que empujó porque vemos bien en las
proyecciones de sillas para la segunda
vuelta dentro de una semana que la
plataforma de la mayoría de lo que desde
el poder de la mayoría presidencial
sale encabezando la próxima asamblea
vamos el peor para ellos a una mayoría
relativa
a una corta mayoría absoluta ya que en
francia en el parlamento la mayoría
absoluta es de
289 dictados y las proyecciones revelan
de una posibilidad de 255 hasta 295
entonces es electricidad que captamos
esa noche a los resultados es porque ya
es a la futura mayoría va a ser reactiva
o más corta va a haber tensiones con el
bloque de izquierdas sin duda entonces
ahí va a haber unos debates mucho más
fuertes que durante los cinco últimos
años donde la plataforma presidencial
tenía una larga amplia mayoría absoluta
lo que le permitió llevar a cabo el
programa de manuel marco de
te va a tener que vivir el parlamento va
a tener que tomar su papel es decir el
debate promoción de proyectos de ley
para la mayoría y por supuesto pues
denunciar los proyectos por una
oposición que va a ser un oposición de
izquierda último punto la abstención
desgraciadamente fuerte 53 por ciento es
algo totalmente
inédito
y justamente tenemos ya resultados
también preliminares son los mejor
resultados sino estimaciones de una
abstención en que llega aproximadamente
al 53 punto
8 %
52.3 exactamente está la estimación de
ipsos para la abstención y le pregunto a
usted por qué cree que que esta
situación está ocurriendo si pues creo
primero que es un proceso ya desde 20
años vemos
hablar el nivel de abstención que se
refuerza porque porque la sociedad está
cambiando porque estamos ya en temas más
globales más europeos y que es muy
importante volver a lo cotidiano volver
a la vida real de las de la gente de los
compatriotas cuya mayoría enfrenta
dificultades sociales entonces de eso de
eso se trata para que ya una nueva
percepción del enlace al poder aparezca
de nuevo en francia que se pueda decir
lo el poder los seres tejidos de verdad
me representan hincha
y las necesidades de la mayoría la
mayoría pues que trabajadora bueno
volvemos con nuestra corresponsal en
parís natalia ruiz natalia le pregunto
cuáles son esas reformas que pretende
impulsar en manuel macro ni que estarían
en juego dentro de esta nueva
legislatura
pues quizás la principal de esas
reformas es la reforma pensional y es
que va a ser digamos la
gran
digamos la gran reforma que él va a
tener que llevar a cabo que fue uno de
los puntos esenciales a lo largo de toda
esa batalla por las elecciones
presidenciales él ha hablado de pues de
la edad de pensión que debería pasar a
los 64 65 años y allí es donde hay
digamos una de las partes más
importantes de desacuerdo entre la
izquierda entre la derecha e incluso
entre las mismas derechas no están de
acuerdo en que esta edad en que esta
jubilación pues pase a los 65 años
actualmente es de 62 algunos partidos
también han pedido que pase de hecho a
los 60 años y se tenga en cuenta también
todo lo que tiene que ver alrededor de
la pena habilidad debilidad del trabajo
de aquellos
cargos de aquellos puestos de trabajo en
donde pues hay todo un desgaste físico
que debe también tenerse en cuenta así
que esa es la principal la reforma que
él pues va a llevar a cabo en todo caso
ese es en todo caso lo que busca es era
uno de sus puntos principales de su
programa presidencial pero efectivamente
ahora con estos resultados el día de hoy
esperar a lo que pueda suceder dentro de
ocho días podría complicarse mucho para
él en caso de que sea la izquierda a la
que se quede con una amplia mayoría en
la asamblea nacional
pues quiero volver con el señor pascal
porque también tenemos también un
porcentaje de votación por agrupación
las estimaciones que hacéis para venta
para france 24 que dice que juntos
tendría un 25 2% esa coalición liderada
por el partido de manuel macrón y nueva
unión popular ecologista y social
también tendría un
25,2 por ciento de de la votación un
18,9 por ciento estaría para
agrupaciones nacional y un 13% 13 7%
para los republicanos
quiero preguntarle señor pascal porque
sacando el mismo porcentaje de votación
en macro ni sus aliados tendrían menos
curules de las que tendrían sus
contrincantes
eso es el sistema por cierto electoral
francés sufragio universal directo al
dos vueltas y por cierto ahí pone el
dedo sobre la realidad electoral de esta
elección se está eligiendo
577 diputados en
577 distritos si quiere
circunscripciones curules sitios
577 realidades diferentes donde se va a
tener que elegir escoger entre los dos
finalistas el finalista ponemos de nunca
es el finalista de juntos y ahí si entra
un mecanismo el primero electoral cuál
es el programa como bien dijo su
corresponsal el programa que de verdad
queremos
estamos a un mes de la elección
presidencial
donde hubo diferencias entre el programa
de manuel ma como sobre europa sobre el
poder adquisito que hoy en día es el
tema con otros temas y él nos dijo las
pensiones temas sociales temas de
blocaje de los precios lo que propone la
nubes ya que tenemos una inflación a
raíz de la guerra que se está librando a
las puertas de la unión europea bueno
hay todo un contexto que hace que el
electorado en el momento de votar llevar
va a pensar damos al presidente los
medios de llevar a cabo su candidatura
o no y de entrar en tiempos un poco de
turbulencia entonces eso es un primer
mecanismo segundo pues porque ahí se da
la ventaja al llegar a la primera
posición y sin duda el que llega a la
primera posición que recibe apoyos está
en situación de tener de poder ganar
entonces son tantos mecanismos que
favorecen por cierto el partido o la
fuerza por siga ya instalada lo que es
el caso de indulto bueno al señor
drogado analista político muchas gracias
por su análisis y quiero hacerle una
última pregunta a natalia cómo quedan
entonces los ánimos de los partidos de
cara a esta segunda vuelta electoral que
tendrá lugar la próxima semana
bueno pues aquí en esta sede de nubes lo
cierto es que hay ese ambiente de
ganadores ambiente de haber obtenido una
victoria importante el día de hoy por
supuesto queda lo que pase dentro de
ocho días pero para ellos pues está
claro que están avanzando y que están
logrando finalmente lo que se habían
propuesto que es eso pasar por enfrente
de esa coalición de emanuel marco por
supuesto de manera más como justamente
cuando les decía que él hablaba de esa
humildad con la que hay que recibir
estos estos resultados pues también
tiene que ver con que viene una semana
de muchísimo trabajo una semana en la
que van a tener que convencer al
electorado de que hay que votar por
ellos porque finalmente en la mayoría en
al menos un poco más de 500
circunscripciones pues el duelo va a ser
precisamente entre la coalición de
izquierda y esa coalición alrededor de
emanuel mayo gracias natalia desde parís
y para terminar este tema pues vamos a
analizar los resultados o no los
resultados sino más bien la estimación
que tiene visos sobre la composición de
la asamblea nacional
unión popular ecologista y social
tendría entre 150 y 190 escaños mientras
que juntos liderado por el partido de
manuel macro tendría entre 255 y 295
escaños hay que recordar de todas
maneras que se necesitan doscientos
ochenta y nueve curules para garantizar
la mayoría en el parlamento francés
cambiamos de información porque el
portavoz del ministerio de defensa de
rusia afirmó que fue destruido un
depósito en ucrania donde se almacenaban
misiles portátiles y otras municiones
suministradas por estados unidos y
europa el mayor general igor konashénkov
dijo el domingo que misiles de largo
alcance y alta precisión lanzados desde
el mar golpearon el lugar cerca del
asentamiento del sur kif en la región de
eterno pela
el caliber de alta precisión y largo
alcance lanzados desde el mar
destruyeron un gran almacén cerca del
asentamiento de chartis región de
ternopil con sistemas de misiles
antitanques sistemas portátiles de
misiles antiaéreos proyectiles de
artillería para sistemas de armas
suministrado al régimen de kiev desde
eeuu y países europeos
y este domingo 12 de junio se celebra el
día mundial contra el trabajo infantil
una actividad que según la organización
internacional del trabajo desempeñan
unos 160 millones de niños y niñas
alrededor del mundo en costa de márfil
en áfrica occidental- más de 800.000
menores trabajan en las plantaciones de
cacao según un estudio de la universidad
de chicago realizado en 2019
situada a 300 kilómetros al oeste de
abiyán la región del agua es una de las
mayores zonas agrícolas de costa de
marfil también uno de los territorios
más afectados por el trabajo infantil
hoy sabin tiene 18 años nunca fue a la
escuela porque su abuela la cuidaba en
el campo pues que ganó cámara cuando
nuestros amigos iban a la escuela ella
quería que fuéramos pero no podía
permitírselo así que no tuvo más y dio
que enviarnos al campo al igual que xavi
el 90% de los casos de trabajo infantil
se producen en el seno de la familia y
suelen suponer el abandono de la escuela
pero en este centro dedicado a la
acogida de niños víctimas de la trata o
del trabajo forzado también hay muchos
niños de países vecinos fatal un chico
de 15 años de burkina faso fue recogido
en un campo de cacao hace una semana
fatal o no es víctima del trabajo
forzado sino de la trata de personas
desde burkina una red organizada lo
llevó a costa de marfil
los burkineses los malienses cuando
tienen un hijo en costa de marfil para
ello eso es algo seguro así que todo el
mundo quiere tener un hijo aquí con un
producto como el cacao que atrae a todo
el mundo de vivir del cacao
sharp y pulmón el cacao representa el 14
por ciento del producto interno bruto de
costa de marfil es la actividad más
afectada por el trabajo infantil en el
país por lo tanto es en las aldeas de
los plantadores donde tratan de
concientizar a los adultos esta brigada
contra el trabajo infantil viene a
reunirse con el jefe del pueblo para
transmitir un mensaje sencillo al
dirigirse a los líderes de la comunidad
la brigada espera a llegar a todo el
pueblo
pueden ser nuestros reemplazos el jefe
está ahí él también tiene reuniones
puede hablar con los que pueden ser
reacios para mostrarles los beneficios
otro lo que hace según las últimas
estimaciones para 2019 15 millones de
menores trabajaban en el sector del
cacao en costa de marfil y ghana
hasta que este resumen informativo yo
los invito a que continúen con nosotros
para conocer todos los detalles de esta
elección en parlamentaria en francia
feliz tarde para todos
[Música]